stocks opened this morning in record
territory after passing another big
milestone for the first time the Dow
crossed the 25 thousand mark on Thursday
that is the third record high in the
first three trading days of the new year
CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is in Chicago
melody good morning what a start to the
new year what's fueling this growth Wow
that's all I can say it was quite a
start we've broken through lots and lots
of Records last year started this year
off strong and a lot of it has to do
with the fact that corporate profits
have been strong should only get better
because of the recent tax cut that
Congress has delivered to them
unemployment is really low the economy
not just in America but around the world
is really strong and not to mention the
fact that some of these deregulation
efforts will push a lot of industries to
have make it easier for them to do
business so there's a lot that is
conspiring to push the stock market up
and yet I'm looking at the front page of
The Wall Street Journal and they point
out though that despite this surge small
investors have continued to yank their
money out of funds that own US stocks
why because they are suffering from what
I call post-traumatic stress disorder
from the financial crisis small
investors have mostly said on the
sidelines because the financial crisis
really scared them and so as a result of
that they have missed a lot of this
rotten in terms of direct ownership of
stocks but they indirectly owned stocks
through their retirement accounts like
their 401k plans and pensions that
they've had so a lot of workers have
still benefited melody what about
average Americans who don't own stocks
and are looking to see economic
increases in things like wages those
have only risen less than 3% in the last
year how do you explain that discrepancy
so wage growth has been very very slow
very low and this is something that's
confounded a lot of economists a lot of
this has to do with the fact again
coming out of the financial crisis
unemployment surged and people literally
gave up looking for a job they said I'm
done as the economy started to come back
these people are entering the workforce
they're willing to work for Less but now
we have 18 states that have raised
unemployment as of the first of this
year we have thirteen states that have
40 year
Loes and unemployment so in order to
hire people they are going to have to
pay them more so I expect wage growth to
really start to happen I've been saying
that for a while but I really do think
this is it could also be a correction on
the horizon somewhere down the line no
one knows I mean this is the thing I
love this saying that bull markets do
not die of old age that is not what
happens it's something else everyone's
pointing to the fact that this is the
second-longest bull market in stock
market history and if we go another ten
months it will be the longest but who
knows
I would not time the market here Mellody
Hobson thanks for that